rund eine Woche hat Markus Söder
gezögert jetzt hat er entschieden Hubert
Aiwanger bleibt Mitglied im Kabinett
Söder und stellvertretender
Ministerpräsident trotz
Antisemitismus-Vorwürfen wie kam der
CSU-Chef zu diesem Beschluss und welche
Rolle spielte dabei die Angst vor
Stimmverlusten fünf Wochen vor der
Landtagswahl in Bayern rede ich darüber
mit dem CSU-Chef und Ministerpräsidenten
von Bayern in Bernau am Chiemsee
herzlich willkommen zum ZDF
sommerinterview
[Musik]
hallo Herr Söder herzlich grüß Gott in
Bayern ich grüße Sie herzlich willkommen
zum ZDF sommerinterview gerne das ist
kein ganz normales sommerinterview heute
ist eine Menge los ich will trotzdem
kurz vorstellen wo wir sind wir treffen
uns hier in Bernau am Chiemsee wir
treffen sie praktisch zwischen vielen
Terminen als Ministerpräsident und auf
ihrer Wahlkampftour sie sind in den
vergangenen Wochen in über 110
Bierzelten gewesen und wenn ich sie mal
nach der Stimmung Frage was war diese
Woche anders ja eigentlich im normalen
Bierzelt gar nichts anderes sondern das
waren volle Veranstaltung ich war
gestern zum Beispiel in Karpfen im
großen Fest in Niederbayern über 5000
Leute waren da und soweit mein Eindruck
haben sich sehr gefreut natürlich
beschäftigen sich die Menschen haben
sich die Woche mit der Causa beschäftigt
einfacher das war ganz klar aber die
Grundstimmung ist gerade nochmal zur CSU
und zum Ministerin war sehr sehr positiv
aber es braucht halt eine Entscheidung
die habe ich jetzt auch getroffen haben
sie es nicht gemacht über den Rest reden
wir jetzt sofort bei uns am Set ich
freue mich
[Musik]
Hubert Aiwanger darf bleiben nach 25
Antworten und einem langen persönlichen
Gespräch mit Ihnen was genau hat Sie
überzeugt ich wurde ein faires und ein
geordnetes Verfahren haben es ging ja um
schwere Vorwürfe Antisemitismus da gibt
es keinen Platz dafür in Bayern dafür
stehe ich auch ganz persönlich aber
andererseits waren es auch eine
Berichterstattung in der Zeitung
Berichte bzw wichtig sich ein eigenes
Bild zu machen und noch eine anfänglich
aus meiner Sicht unglücklichen
Krisenkommunikation von ihm selbst aber
die 25 Fragen gestellt und haben dann
auch ein langes persönliches Gespräch
geführt ich fasse es mal so zusammen es
sieht so aus dass er in seiner Jugend
wohl Fehler gemacht hat der dazugegeben
er hat sie auch bereut dass der eine
Teil der zweite Teil ist es gab aber
keinen handfesten Beweis der die
Vorwürfe insbesondere dieses Flugplatzes
bestätigt hätte
und zum anderen ist das ganze 35 Jahre
her das ist seitdem auch wirklich nichts
dazu gekommen und deswegen schien mir in
der Gesamtabwägung
ist unverhältnismäßig eine Entlassung
vorzunehmen und deswegen ist die
Entscheidung aus meiner Sicht
sachgerecht ich gebe zu das ist eine
schwere Entscheidung gewesen aber ich
habe sie nach besten Wissen und Gewissen
getroffen sie haben innerhalb dieses
Prozesses innerhalb der Woche mal gesagt
sie wollen eine zweifelsfreie Aufklärung
heute haben sie in ihrem Statement
gesagt die Antworten waren nicht alle
befriedigend warum rücken sie von ihrem
ursprünglichen Maßstab denn ab wir haben
die 25 Fragen gestellt die würden dann
tatsächlich beantwortet und nicht alle
waren befriedigend das stimmt
einige war noch sehr bekannt es war auch
vieles mit nicht erinnern bleiben
was ist nicht und wenn ich die
gesamtabdeckung treffe gibt es keinen
harten klaren Beweis für die Vorwürfe
für die schweren Vorwürfe für die
gemacht worden sind in den in den Medien
auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen
Seite 35 Jahre her seitdem ist es ist
übrigens auch ganz interessant gewesen
die Woche wurde ja viel auch
recherchiert und nachgefragt seit diesem
Zeitraum er war 16 damals hat sich keine
Veränderung ergeben hat sich nichts
Neues ergeben und der hat in dem Fragen
und es war für mich sozusagen mit sich
auch der entscheidende Punkt gesagt dass
dieser Prozess von damals etwas
ausgelöst habe in ihm selber seine
Vorstellung zu verändern und in den
persönlichen Gespräch war so dass er
sehr angefasst war also ich habe gemerkt
dass sie eine sehr betroffen hat und das
war für mich schon ein ganz wichtiger
Eindruck und so kam ich am Ende zu der
Abwägung das ist nicht angemessen wäre
das ist ein übermaßwert eine Entlassung
vorzunehmen also habe ich nach Augenmaß
entschieden sie haben das Miteinander
abgewogen sie kommen allerdings trotzdem
da würde ich noch mal gerne darauf
eingehen von dem von dem Willens es
zweifelsfrei aufzuklären wenn man mal
schaut sie haben die Fragen und die
Antworten veröffentlicht gut ein Drittel
der Fragen hat Aiwanger sinngemäß
beantwortet mit habe ich nicht mehr in
Erinnerung das entzieht sich meiner
Kenntnis das kann ich nicht beantworten
ist das tatsächlich Aufklärung
ich will jetzt keine Vergleichsfälle in
der Bundespolitik ziehen wo ganz
namhafte deutsche Politiker sichern
Dinge nicht erinnern können die vor zwei
Jahren waren
ein bisschen von Entscheidungsgrundlage
setzen Dinge die 35 Jahre her sind wird
es uns beiden wahrscheinlich auch nicht
ganz leicht fallen jedes Detail in
Erinnerung zu haben und deswegen muss
ich dann ja mit dem was sozusagen
treffen und ich hatte das Gefühl dass
auch seinen
eine Reue und auch seine seine
Distanzierung von dem Flugblatt und dem
Inhalt des Flugplatz des
zugegebenermaßen ekelhaft widerlich oder
reiner nazi- war das war für mich
glaubhaft am Ende diese Distanzierung
und insofern war es eine
Abwägungsentscheidung am Schluss ich
habe das ja gesagt ich will mir auch
nicht ganz leicht sage ich ausdrücklich
dazu aber irgendwann muss man als
Ministerpräsident eine Entscheidung
treffen und die muss am Ende auch fair
sein übrigens auch fair der Person
gegenüber und die muss ich halt dann
treffen ich habe ja gemacht und deswegen
verstehe ich dazu der Entscheidung dazu
ich erhoffe sehr dass er auch die
Entscheidung dann auch vernünftig
annimmt die haben z.B auch gemeinsam
besprochen es war noch ein Anliegen
jetzt mit den jüdischen Organisationen
und Gemeinden ins Gespräch zu kommen es
wird auch machen auch das haben wir zum
Beispiel auch mit Frau Knoblauch und
dann Schuster schon im Vorfeld
besprochen es wird jetzt wichtig sein
weiter aufzuarbeiten und vor allen
Dingen seine persönliche Glaubwürdigkeit
wieder zurückzugeben sie hatten eine
zweite klare Messlatte eingezogen
nämlich es darf nichts mehr dazu kommen
das haben sie ganz klar so gesagt dann
kam aber noch einfacher als Umgang mit
der ganzen Sache dazu und sie haben auch
heute gesagt leider habe sein
Krisenmanagement die Glaubwürdigkeit
nicht erhöht auch das lassen sie ihm zu
durchgehen das liegt ja nicht 35 Jahre
zurück nein sie sind völlig recht was
ein 16-Jähriger macht ist nicht so
entscheiden es kommt schon darauf an wie
man dann als 52-Jährige damit umgeht und
sie haben auch recht ich habe das auch
betont das gerade am Anfang des
Krisenmanagement und sagen wir mal sehr
unglücklich war er hat dann aber am
Donnerstag und das ist jetzt der
positive Aspekt wieder dann sich klar
davon distanziert hat sich entschuldigt
hat auch bereut wenn er Gefühle verletzt
haben sollte das war spät aber es war
nicht zu spät und gleich danach hat er
hat er auch wieder von einer
Schmutzkampagne gesprochen aber ich
möchte auch mal Eingehen auf die man
selbst man merkt es auch richtig wenn
man mit ihm redet natürlich in einer
persönlichen Ausnahmesituation da würde
ich jetzt auch nicht jedes Wort und auch
jede Emotion auf die goldwa gelegen fakt
ist aber schon für mich war wichtig dass
diese Entschuldigung Erfolg ist diese
klare Distanzierung sowohl von dem
Flugplatz selber als auch von möglichen
Verfehlungen die stattfanden jenseits
des Flugblattes da gab es ja auch eine
Reihe von Berichten darüber und ja
deswegen sagen wir so wenn Sie mir wenn
sie mir jetzt noch zahlen
das geht auch nicht nur um Hubert
Aiwanger wir haben auch andere Probleme
sowohl in Deutschland als auch in Bayern
deswegen habe ich dann natürlich wieder
ein faires Verfahren haben und ich muss
als Ministerpräsident ja auch ein Land
zusammenhalten ich kann ja nicht einfach
nur aus einer SM Gefühl heraus
entscheiden das habe ich halt dann so
versucht so fair und geordnet wie
möglich zu machen geht allerdings über
die Diskussion in Bayern hinaus sie
haben nicht ohne Grund gesagt Bayern ist
ein Bollwerk gegen Antisemitismus denn
es geht auch um die Frage wie gehen wir
mit Antisemitismus wie gehen wir mit
Erinnerungskultur um und sie halten
jetzt einen Vize Amt der noch vor
wenigen Tagen gesagt hat in seinen Augen
werde die Schuhe zu parteipolitischen
Zwecken gegen ihn und die Freien Wähler
Missbrauch da gab es schon Reaktionen
darauf für Jüdinnen und Juden ist das
ein Schlag ins Gesicht für alle die sich
mit Erinnerungskultur auseinandersetzen
und sich dann Mühe gegeben ist das eine
Zumutung wie kann so jemand der so
spricht weiter im Amt ist viel zu
bleiben also zunächst immer glaube ich
ist die Haltung bei uns insgesamt klar
noch meine eigene Person es hat auch ja
Entscheidungen gegeben ich habe Preise
der jüdischen rabbinerkonferenz bekommen
für unser noch für mein persönliches
Engagement
in München zu haben die Medien haben
übrigens das was sie jetzt fragen ist
ihre Haltung dich respektiere wenn ich
das ganze
es gab auch Reaktionen aus den Medien
die die Dinge unterschiedlich wir werden
es anderen Teilen das hat tatsächlich
viel polarisiert und ich habe auch mehr
als Verständnis wenn die Gefühlswelt in
der Sache sehr auseinandergeht deswegen
war sie auch beispielsweise wie ich
jetzt nicht nach einer Emotionen
entscheide ist sondern am Ende nach
einem ganz
Beton ist immer wieder mit dem
geordneten Verfahren was ist belegbar
was ist der Beweis welche Relation steht
zu den Dingen hat man sich entschuldigt
ja das ist passiert
hat man sich davon distanziert auch auch
von den ganzen antisemitischen ganz klar
davon distanziert und deswegen bleibe
ich dann am Ende dabei etwas aus 35
Jahre her ist und wo man heute sich klar
davon distanziert das wäre ein Übermaß
dort eine Entlassung sie sehen diese
Distanzierung anderen reicht das nicht
Ruprecht Polenz CDU Urgestein spricht
sogar in diesem Zusammenhang weil er
albernheim am bleiben kann von einem
Dammbruch und die bundesinnenministerin
Nancy fazer sagt dass Herr Söder dies
zulässt schadet dem Ansehen unseres
Landes ist Ihnen bewusst dass sie mit
dieser Entscheidung den Maßstab für den
Umgang mit mit Antisemitismus und
Erinnerungskultur verschieben nein ich
sehe das genau andersrum also zunächst
mal was drauf ist jetzt im Wahlkampf das
ist Wahlkampf ist auch tatsächlich ein
bisschen
spannend zu sehen das nochmal der
Bundeskanzler völlig lassen Sie mich
doch einfach die Meinung sagen wie ich
es empfinde ja und auch der
Bundeskanzler sagt da müssen Fragen
aufgeklärt werden die sich an ihnen an
der Stelle auch gewaltig richten ich
finde sogar dass ich einen der eine neue
Qualität im Umgang auch mit Vorwürfen
die in den Medien gemacht wird schauen
Sie mal stellen sich doch auch Fragen im
medialen Umfeld es gibt die Geschichte
selber ich antworte jetzt wie es für
richtig empfinde ich glaube das ist sehr
viele Bürger gibt die auch ein bisschen
kritisch sind wieder Ungarn ist
Journalismus mit vielen Themen ist ich
würde das sogar als ein Teil der
gesamten Debatte jetzt hier betrachten
die Geschichte scheint ja auch so haben
es gelesen ich glaube sogar im Spiegel
auch anderen Medien angeboten worden zu
sein die haben es aber nicht abgedruckt
weil sie offensichtlich das nicht als so
stark empfunden haben deswegen stellt
sich auch die Frage dass man nach einem
Medienberichterstattung nicht sein
abschließendes Urteil fällen sollte
sondern
nicht das ist genau das was ich halt
antworten will bin ich um finde sicher
mir die Woche wahrscheinlich mehr
Gedanken gemacht dass viele andere Leute
darüber und ich bin da auch mit mir
selber mehr als schwanger gegangen was
der richtige Weg ist und ich fand dass
das am Ende nicht dass jemand kann mal
schnell ein Tweet schreiben durch den
sie jetzt auch abholens schätzt ihn sehr
ja ist aber weit weg von Bayern und auch
von vielen politischen Prozessen ich
habe am Ende ein aus meiner Sicht nicht
einfachen aber substanzierten Prozess
aufgesetzt der am Ende eines saubere
Abwägung gebracht hat und damit auch den
Umgang damit glaube ich vernünftig
geregelt hat wenn man sich die
Kommentare so anschaut die jetzt im Netz
schon unterwegs sind dann sieht man das
viele den Verdacht haben der Wahlkampf
in Bayern könnte eine Rolle gespielt
haben robert awanger hat sehr früh
gesagt Schmutzkampagnen gehen am Ende
nach hinten los er bekam sehr viel
Applaus von seinen Unterstützern dafür
und auch darüber hinaus war bei ihnen am
Ende bei dieser Entscheidung auch die
Angst vor dem Solidarisierungseffekt für
Herrn awanger in der Wahl zu groß Angst
ist für mich keinen Spaß weil wenn mich
kennt weiß das Axt ist auch kein Motiv
ist am Ende ging es mir drin einfach
fair zu sein mir ging es einfach im Fans
und Frau Felser die er selber auch im
Wahlkampf ist und vielleicht ein
bisschen sich vorstellen kann wie es
Ihnen geht sagt aber Herr Söder hat
nicht aus Haltung und Verantwortung
entschieden sondern aus schlichtem
machtkalkühl also noch einmal also Frau
Fehse ist noch wirklich eine der Maßstab
für eine Entscheidung und Bayern wir
werden ja sehen wie viel Unterstützung
Frau fesam in den Hessen bekommt und es
einzuordnen und ich finde sie sollte
sich mal lieber messen und zum Teil in
Deutschland kümmern das wäre besser
angesagt praktisch eine kleine
Strafarbeit aufgegebener kleinere kann
man braucht man gar nicht so
einzuschränken sie haben ihm gesagt er
muss jetzt noch mal mit Aufarbeitung
sich auseinandersetzen er muss mit
jüdischen Institutionen zusammenarbeiten
vor der Wahl entlassen sie ihn nicht
wenn Sie sich anschauen wie er sich dann
verhält wie sieht es danach der Wahl aus
kann Herr Albaner nach der Wahl Mitglied
in einem möglichen neuen Kabinett werden
also erstmal es kam mir gemeinsam zu der
Überzeugung dass dieses Gespräch mit den
jüdischen Gemeinden zwingend notwendig
ist also gemeinsame Entscheidung ich bin
auch nicht der Oberlehrerin zu
entscheiden Ministerpräsident und ich
versuche
auch ein Land zusammenzuhalten und in
der Tat Schaden abzuwehren aber ist auch
so zu machen dass ein Großteil der
Bevölkerung versteht warum und wie ich
entscheide so und deswegen glaube ich
ist es einfach zwingend notwendig sich
mit diesem Thema auch selbst glaubhaft
zu beschäftigen und nicht nur zu sagen
ich bin dagegen sondern auch im Gespräch
das glaubhaft zu dokumentieren wir in
Bayern sitzen Klarheit auf die Koalition
mit den freien Willen wir haben fünf ja
gut zusammengearbeitet übrigens auch
keinen Zweifel gehabt an seine Haltung
es muss jetzt wirklich dazu sagen mir
war noch nie irgendwelche Anzeichen für
ein solches Verhalten bekannt deswegen
gab es da auch bei uns Überraschung
damals über die Berichterstattung und ja
also bei uns schwarz grün in Bayern das
wollen wir nicht also das ist ja auch
ganz interessant wissen Sie die
Opposition in Bayern hat ja dann während
der Woche auch mehrfach versucht
öffentlich oder sogar nicht öffentlich
sich quasi ein bisschen anzubieten als
alternativpartner deswegen sind auch die
Kommentierungen aus der Opposition
heraus ein bisschen wärmer wenig
überzeugend und scheinheilig aber ja wir
setzen die Koalition fort auf die Frage
war dabei haben sie jetzt nicht klar
geantwortet aber schauen wir noch mal
was anderes Thema ist davon aus dann es
wäre ja sehr viel einfacher für Sie wenn
die CSU deutlich über 40 Prozent wäre
das ist sie aber momentan nicht in
unfragen sondern sie bleiben nach dem
historisch schlechten Wahlergebnis vom
letzten Mal noch unter 40 Prozent Horst
Seehofer hat über die Chancen der CSU
gesagt im Prinzip wäre eine absolute
Mehrheit zu holen von ihnen hört man das
gar nicht mehr trauen sie sich das nicht
zu nein das war absinn davon dass zum
Beispiel dem großen Wahljahr 2013 muss
eine absolute Mehrheit gehabt gar keine
AFD gehabt in Bayern Antrag die nun das
sind wir national hier in Umfragen ist
die weitaus stärker sind als es je zuvor
war es wäre das aus meiner Sicht aber
auch soll ich sagen ein bisschen
überheblich wenn Parteien in der Phase
in der unser Land ist unser Land lebt
gerade im Moment von einer beginnenden
schweren wirtschaftlichen Schwäche über
diese reden müssen und wo die
Bundesregierung offenkundig kein
ernsthaftes Konzept hat noch nie hat
eine Bundesregierung auch so wenig
Vertrauen in der Bevölkerung hat weil
sie sich mit sich beschäftigt Menschen
bleiben unter 40 %, aber das ist glaube
ich unter den Gesichtspunkten wie im
Moment die Situation ist wir haben freie
Wähler und AFD liegen wir da sogar finde
ich sehr stabil mir kommt es aber auch
nicht auf das Prozent an ich finde das
immer so eine so eine schönheitskür die
von Journalisten und Politikern gerne
gemacht wird mir konzentrieren ja
stabiles regieren stabiles regieren und
ich glaube das kann man schon sagen in
Bayern das seriöse starke und stabile
Zentrum der bayerischen Politik ist der
Ministerpräsident und die CSU das
Wahlergebnis geht auf jeden Fall am Ende
mit Ihnen nach Hause und deswegen ist
vielleicht auch die Frage berechtigt
welchen Anteil haben Sie eigentlich in
der aktuellen Lage in der CSU mein
Kollege mattes Feldhoff fast das in 60
Sekunden zusammen
für Markus Söder kann sich am 8 Oktober
so viel entscheiden kann er sein
historisch schlechtes Ergebnis
verbessern oder bleibt er wieder unter
40 Prozent Söder ist nicht unumstritten
Söder polarisiert im August ergibt eine
Umfrage 51% Zustimmung 46% haben keine
gute Meinung von ihm eine zweite Umfrage
auch aus dem August sieht die
Zufriedenheit sogar nur bei 40% 49% sind
unzufrieden mit ihm das könnte seine
Ursache in Söders Hang zur politischen
Sprunghaftigkeit haben gestern grünen
versteher heute ihr größter Gegner am
Anfang corona-team Vorsicht am Ende Team
Öffnung und auch die Schwesterpartei hat
ihre Erfahrungen gemacht nicht wenige
bei den Christdemokraten sehen die
Schuld für die Wahl Niederlage vor zwei
Jahren bei dem Bayern Markus Söder sucht
immer die Lösung Designer macht nutzt ob
es der CSU oder gar der Union als Ganzes
hilft scheint oft weiter nicht
und ich habe noch eine umfragezahl für
sie vom Bayerischen Rundfunk da sagen 76
Prozent der Bayern Markus Söder
polarisiert wenn ein Wahlkampf so sehr
auf eine Person zugeschnitten ist wie
das bei Ihnen der Fall ist dann ist das
doch keine gute Zahl oder abgesehen von
das ist eine Umfrage ist 72% sondern sie
wollen keinen anderen Ministerpräsident
als Markus fütter glaube ich wird es ein
bisschen wieder mal selektiv aber das
ist natürlich ihre Sache wie sie das
bewerten wollen am Ende entscheiden die
Wälder ich arbeite rund um die Uhr für
Bayern ich glaube Bayern ist das
erfolgreichste Land in Deutschland
bekommen auch besser durch die Krise als
alle anderen Länder wir haben ein hohes
Maß an Stabilität nicht dieses Ampel
gehabt hin und her wir treffen klare
Entscheidungen in allen Rankings
wirtschaftlich sozialbildungspolitisch
gegen vorne lebt sich einfach besser und
das ist am Ende glaube ich die
entscheidende darüber 90% dabei Bayern
leben kann da also ich glaube wir sind
auf einem sehr guten Weg und meine
Aufgabe ist jetzt nicht danach zu
schielen was für mich das beste ist
sondern was für unser Land ist
glaube ich einfach dass wir da Bayern
gut unterwegs sind wir könnten noch
besser sein wenn in Deutschland die
Rahmenbedingungen besser sind aber ich
denke um Bayern bleibt stark und stabil
gerade auch mit einer starken Sessel mit
all den Zahlen die Sie gerade genannt
haben muss man auch dazu sagen ein
Viertel der Bayern sieht die Zukunft des
Landes nicht bei der CSU aktuell sondern
wählt rechts von der CSU verspielen sie
da gerade das Erbe von Franz Josef
Strauß der den der den der den Sprung
nehmen mit der AFD dann ist es momentan
von Franz Josef Strauß das rechts von
der CSU
ihre Einschätzung fand ich nicht fair
also ich wollte einfach nur mal bemerken
ich teile diese Einschätzung von ihnen
jetzt alles unter also AFD und
freiwiller gleichzusetzen teile ich
nicht das ist das meiner Sicht ein
unzulässiger Einschätzung
wir haben gesagt rechts von Mercedes so
das weiß ich nicht sagen
in einem Gegenteil ich glaube Franz
Josef Strauß würde uns in der Frage
sogar ausdrücklich unterstützen Franzl
stause sind an der Zeit auch dran
gekommen da erinnern wir uns beide aus
persönlicher Erinnerung nicht in der es
bayern-parteien Landes gab es war nicht
selbstverständlich dass die CSU damals
absolute Mehrheiten hatte und da gab es
auch schwierige Zeiten wissen sie haben
ja recht dass das alles nicht so einfach
ist wie vielleicht vor 20 25 Jahren da
kann aber ich nichts dafür da können
viele andere nichts dafür ich muss in
der Zeit in der ich lebe das Beste
erreichen und ein eine Krisen die wir
haben meistern und eine Partei auch
dafür motivieren und sich engagieren
lassen durchzusteuern und ich glaube
wenn sie mal Umfragen auch national
sehen gibt es sehr viele Menschen die da
Auffassung sind dass wir das in Bayern
gar nicht so schlecht machen in fünf
Wochen wird gewählt und die einwanger
Debatte ist vermutlich noch nicht zu
Ende aber an diesem an dieser Stelle
hier endet unsere Gespräch heute
das war unser letztes ZDF
sommer-interview in diesem Jahr in der
kommenden Woche begrüßt sie meinen
Kollege Theo Kreuz zu einer neuen
Ausgabe von Berlin direkt in vielen Dank
fürs zuschauen und einen schönen Abend
[Musik]